[Music]
m
completely I
didn't know
or
[Music]
curves
or
fifth [
Music]
hehehe [
o [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
other shows
at the end I'm going to talk
I say it in the forest
there is no money allocated
with  this white tactical help
look
com
is no longer
and so
with my fans
well well
[Music]
to me
or not
or yes
I am
how
[Music]
look
[Applause]
[Music]
and I was to have been
ready
for the bbc to see from  what a way
well
come back
d
and
ah
let's notice
[Applause] let's
see
about this
yes
ah
[Music]
well
yes no
ah
no mames
mmmm
and his beloved is teachers want to do
[Music]
isabel municipal
and managed
[Music]
the grapes
télam
nothing
aymerich
here
fine
[Music]
and I
meditate I
believe in facebook
with mother [ __ ] to knit
[Music]
I see it's green